اهلا بكم من جديد في الخامس من ديسمبر
شهدت العاصمه السودانيه توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي بين الشرق العسكري في مجلس
السياده الحاكم في البلاد وقوى اعلان
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي والمجموعه
المتحالفه معها وهذا لانهاء الازمه
السياسيه في السودان واعادته الى الحكم
المدني وسط حضور دولي واقليمي كبير لاطراف
اسهمت في التواصل الى هذا الاتفاق ويتكون
الاتفاق من المبادئ العامه التي تشمل
ترسيخ مبدا العداله والمحاسبه واليه
العداله الانتقاليه ووضع حد للافلام من
العقاب وايضا التاكيد على جيش مهني واحد
وملتزما بالعقيده العسكريه الموحده واقامه
السلطه المدنيه بالكامل دون مشاركه القوه
النظاميه لكن اليوم نجد تاخرا لاعلان
الاتفاق النهائي بين المكونين العسكري
والمدني عن موعده المحدد دون معرفه
الاسباب لتبدا التساؤلات هل هي تعثر ام ان
الاتفاق لا يتم
الان ان وجود العسكريين في السلطه امر
مواقع
جريمه
[موسيقى]
تاخر الاتفاق بين المدنيين والعسكريين في
السودان
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع
مباركيه ومن الخرطوم ايضا الريح محمد
الصادق عطول مكتب التنفيذي للحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي مرحبا بكم
الكريمين استاذ الريح ابدا معك ما هي
الاسباب الحقيقيه لتاخير توقيع الاتفاق
بين المكونين العسكري والمدنيه في السودان
تحيه لكم للساده المشاهدين اعتقد ان
الاسباب الاساسيه لتاخير التوقيع الاتفاق
النهائي بين المكوين العسكري والجانب
المدني هي النغاشات الطويله والمستمره
داخل المكونات المدنيه حول القضايا التي
تم ذكرها انفا التي هي متعلقه بالسلام
وبالعداله الانتقاليه والعداله والاصلاح
الامني والعسكري
همم الاصلاح المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه
وكذلك اصلاحها منظومه القضائيه هذه
النقاشات اخذت حيزا في ان كيف نصل فيها
لراي موحد ومشترك
فيها الحريه
والمجلس العسكري سيد الرئيس
بين الغوي والمدنيه في ما بينها وبين
القوى المدنيه وبين المكون العسكري ايضا
والان القيمه المدنيه والاطراف والموقعين
على الاتفاق الايطالي بسبب عقد ورش تبدا
من اربعه يناير تنتهي في 17 يناير للوصول
الى الخلاصه النهائيه لهذه النقاشات
والاتفاق حول هذه القضايا وتضمينها داخل
صيغه الدستوريه ويصبح بعد ذلك التوقيع على
الاتجاه النهائي مساله زمن بسيط جدا ولا
اكثر يعني هي المساله مساله وقت فقط يعني
من الرابع من يناير الى 17 يناير
ستذلل هذه العقبات بان نقول ويتم التوقيع
همم همم اعود الى اليك سيد مبارك اردول
لوجه اليك نفس السؤال هل تعتقد فعلا ان
المساله مساله توقيع الاتفاق بين المدنيين
والعسكريين هي مساله وقت فقط هو مجرد
تاخير اجرائي ام ان الاتفاق بين المكونين
قد فشل
طيب شكرا جزيلا لكل المشاهدين والضيفك
بالحقيقه يعني
استعداد شيء المسميات يعني نعم المقاوله
العسكري ولكن ليس المكونه المدنيه وانما
جزء من المقرر المدني ليس كله هم انما فقط
مجموعه المدرسه المركزي
هو الاجابه السؤال ده انا اقول انه هذا
الاتفاق الذي يشك وقع بشكل ثنائي بين ادوس
من المدن العسكري لا يحظى بتاييد من عدد
كبير من الشعب السوداني وبما فيها الشباب
الموجودين في الشارع وعدد كبير من القوى
السياسيه هذا اتفاق الان اتفاق يعني شبه
معزول تماما ولا يتحدث به سوى من وقع عنه
الاصل في الامر ليس الاتفاق حتى
كرنفال للصور والخطابه وانما هي يعني يعني
توافق يخرج البلاد من الازمه السياسيه
التي دخلت فيها منذ العام الماضي وخروج
يعني يعني بالبلاد الى الامام ولكن لقد
بدا واضحا لمن وقعوا ولمن دعم هذا الاتفاق
ان الامر لا يكون كما توقعوه توقع الناس
انه بمجرد التوقيع ان يحتفل الناس كمحتفوا
بالاصدق ضد السوريه في العمل 2019
رفع كل السودانيين وغير السودانيين
وضيوفهم وجيرانهم والنا العالم همم بدايه
عهد جديد ولكن الان يعني للتو كانت هنالك
مظاهرات اليوم وغيرها في الايام الماضيه
جداول المستمره للمظاهرات المباراه الامور
ليست كمال من المكون المدني ولديكم كما
فهمت من كلامك ما اخذ على المكون المدني
عنصر اساسي هو تقصد المجلس المركزي همم
لديكم تحفظات على بعض المسائل المتعلقه
بالاتفاق مع المكونات العسكري ما هي ما
اخذكم هنا بينكم بين المكونات القوى
المدنيه ما هي ما اخذكم على المجلس
المركزي
طيب شكرا جزيلا هذا سؤال مهم جدا يعني نحن
نرى ان لا يجب ان يتم هذا الاتفاق بشكل
ثنائي او في في مناطق مغلقه وفي غرف مغلقه
انما يجب ان يكون الاتفاق شفاف ويشارك فيه
قطاع عريض وعن الاقل المعروض لشعب
السوداني في كل فتره هذه التفاوض وكذلك في
فتره التوقيع وهكذا الطريقه التي تمت
المنهجيه التي تمت بالحوار في مساله
بالخروج بهذا الوثيقه كانت منهجيه مختلطه
تماما هذا من من الطريق وكذلك الاطراف
التي شاركت هي جزء من المشهد وليست هي كل
المشهد بما فيها العسكريه
من هذه النقاشات تقصد بشكل مباشر اريد
حديثا صريحا مباشره
كذلك المكونه العسكريه لم نشارك نحن بما
فيها حتى الدعوات يعني من المؤسف حتى
الدعوات لكي نكون
تحضرهم يوقعون يبارك لهم التوقيع لم
يدعوننا لماذا
اعتقد اعتقد هم يعتقدوننا اننا ليست لدينا
الحق في ان نشارك في اداره الانتقال في
بلادنا
ومنحو انفسهم الحق ليدير البلاد في فتره
الانتقال دعني اعود لنقطه مهمه في
ملاحظاتنا يعني مثلا اذا ذهبنا الى
الهياكل السلطه الانتقاليه مثلا في مساله
القضاء نجد ان هذا الاتفاق او هذا الذي هو
الوسيخه التي وقعت في الخامس من ديسمبر
اعطت المكون السياسي الحق في التدخل في
الدين هذا القضائي والجهاز المحكمه
الدستوريه والنيابه والقضاء وتت تشكلها
بالطريقه التي تراها بواسطه مجلس سموها
مجلس عدلي فهو تدخل سافر يقود الفصل
الكلمه
باختصار لو سمحت لانه اريد رد انتم هنا
يعني تهاجمون الطرف الاخر المجلس المركزي
في الحريه والتغيير فقط اكمل الجزء الثاني
بسرعه حتى نضع مجالا لل سيد
الثاني مثلا ويحاولون الدخول او القاء
اتفاق سلام جوبا ويجملون هذا الحديث
بتقويم هذه اتفاقيه وضعت وسكر
لاكثر من عام ما بين الحكومه السودان
والحركات الكفاح المسلحه اوقفه الحرب
جزئيا في دارفور وفي المنطقين لا يمكن
المساس بها الثالثه اخر شيء هي اعطت هذه
الاتفاق سلطه مطلقه للمكونه للمجلس
المركزي ليشكل الحكومه ولا يتحكم في
الانتقال في الحكومه التنفيذيه وكذلك بما
فيها البرلمان والاجهزه المفوضات وغيرها
هو حقق لا يستحقونه منفرده ان تتحكم في
البلاد حتى اذا كانت تم انتخابها لا يمكن
ان تفوز بنسبه 100% في الانتخابات في
الدوله مثل هذه فهو حق اعطوه لاناس
يستحقونه انا اشكرك الصراحه على صراحتك
الحقيقه وتعبيرك عن ماخذكم على همم
المكونات المدنيه الاخرى همم سيد الريح
محمد الصادق كيف ترد يبدو ان هناك مشكله
ليست فقط بين المدنيين والعسكريين المشكله
فيما بينكم ايضا بين القوى المدنيه هناك
مشاكل كيف ترد على ضيفه السيد المبارك
اردول
ال في الباديه لابد من ان نعود بالتاريخ
لعام للخلف اعتقد ان الازمه هي كانت ازمه
بين العسكريين والمدنيين وادت الى انقلاب
25 اكتوبر حين محاوله العسكريون التحكم
بالانتقال
ومحاوله
تجميع وتصليح الحاضن السياسيه للحكومه
الانتقاليه
وابتكرت عده اجسام لتخلق ازمه الدستوريه
وكان من بينها التوافق الوطني وغيرها من
الاجسام السياسيه الاخرى الان نرى مجموع
كبير من الاجسام السياسيه تم خلقها عقد
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر لذلك نحن في قوى الحريه
والتغيير تحدثنا صراحه عن قوى الثوره وعن
القوى التي رفضت انقلاب 25 اكتوبر
فالحديث عن مثلا عن مثلا عدم استغلاليه
القضاء يا سيدي العزيز الغطاء السوداني
لمده 30 عاما ظل مسيسا وظل ممتلئا
ومخترقا من قواعد الجهاز الامن الشعبي
التابعي للنظام القديم وغيرهم من الخلايا
الاخوانيه الاخرى وكذلك هذا القضاء رايناه
يحدث المهازل في القضايا السودانيه وكذلك
اصبح غير محايد وغير غير مؤهل يعني يكون
غطاء سودانيا مستقلا ونزيهم الان نرى هناك
تضييع للعداله واطلاق سراح لمتهمين بقتل
الشهداء وعرقله في المحاكم ومماطله في
محكمه الذين قاموا بانقلاب الثلاثين من
يونيو لذلك هذا القضاء وهذه النيابه لابد
من اصلاحها ولا بد من تنظيفها وهذا
التنظيف لابد ان يكون من قوه الثوره انا
اعتقد ان الثوره ديسمبر الجهاد بالحريه
والسلام والعداله لابد ان تستثمر في هذه
الاهداف ولابد ان تحققها على ارض الواقع
الحديث عن ان هنالك
محاوله للسطوع على ما هو حديث مشروخ
اسطوانه مشروخ كما يقولون الشيء الاخر
حقوق الحريه والتغيير عندما ارادت ان تذهب
الى الحل السياسي وضعت اهداف ووضعت شروطا
واضحه اول شيء اعتمدت عليه قوه الحريه
والتغيير هو تحديدها للاطراف المتعلقه
بهذه الازمه نعلم تماما بان هناك اقوى
استخدمها الانقلاب في ان كيف يصنع الحاضن
سياسيه
على الساحه السياسيه وهنالك هو اخرى كانت
في صف القوى الثوره والثناء هذا الانقلاب
فهذه القوه بالنسبه لنا هي قوه لابد من
وجودها في الانتقال اعتقد ان القوه التي
صنعها الانقلاب لا يمكن ان تكون جزءا من
هذا الحل وعندما عرضنا هذه الرؤيا وافق
بها المكونه العسكري نحن لن نضغط على اي
احد نحن قلنا وجهه نظرنا في هذا الموضوع
ورفضنا تماما جميع القضايا السودانيه
ويهدار الثوره عن طريق حشوها باطراف
سياسيه غير موجوده اصلا من قبل واطراف
سياسيه هي جزء من تعقيده المشهد السياسي
جزءا من من قتل انقلابيه سيد مبارك كردون
كيف ترد يعني هذه هي الاعتراضات من قبلكم
من قبل بعض المكونات المدنيه ايضا ما هي
الا تمييع للقضيه وكذلك
مساهمه همم في اطاله امد الازمه وبقاء
المكون العسكري في السلطه على حساب
المدنيين
ونشوف انا اهم شيء يجب ان نقوله يعني لا
لا احد منا يدعم وجود العسكريين في السلطه
نحن مع الحكم المدني الكامل ونحن مع
الانتخابات التي يفرون منها لا يريدونها
هؤلاء الحديث عن الانتخابات ده شيء ثاني
شيء ثالث الحديث همم بتصنيف القوى
السياسيه بهذه القوى الثوره هذه هذا
التصنيف نحن نعلم انطلق من صراحه حول
الكراسي ومحافظ الاسياسيه يعني ينظرون
اليها في همم في المستقبل القريب يريدون
يعني همم بهذا التصنيف ان يحصل على مكاسب
اكبر من كراسه الانتقال هؤلاء يعني ليست
الثوره الان انتهت بسقوط نظام البشير
الصراع الان يتمثل في كيفيه اداره
الانتقال والذهاب الى ما بعد الانتقال
الذهاب الانتخابات او لا يريدون يكسرون
ياخذون الكيكه بكاملها هذا هو الاخر نعم
هل الحديث
الا ترى يعني انه الوقت ليس وقت للخلافات
يعني
والتخوين او التشكيك في ذمه الاخر بانه هو
تريد ان يستاثر بالكرسي على حساب يعني
المساله مساله انتقال السودان في مرحله
حرج بعد سقوط نظام البشير الاولويه هي ان
تتوحد جميع القوى المدنيه في سبيل تنظيم
انتخابات والخروج بالنظام جديد ومن بعد
ذلك يتم الحديث عن الخلافات بين المكونات
المدنيه بين القوى السياسيه وتحتكم الى
عمليه سياسيه الا ترى ان هذا هو الاسود ان
يتم الان وتنحيه الخلافات الى ما بعد همم
تطور العمليه السياسيه لانه همم هكذا
ستبقى الاتفاقات كلها فاشله وسيبقى
السودان على ما هو عليها ام لا
بلاشك اتفق معك تماما فيما تقوله ولهذا
لاسباب نحن اسسنا قوى الحريه تغيير
التوافق الوطني في السادس عشر من اكتوبر
الماضي 2021 لهذه النقاط التي ذكرتها يجب
ان نتفق كلنا كقوه سياسيه حول الحد الادنى
من القضايا التي يعني تكون بسيطه تدوير
الانتقال وبعدها نذهب الى الانتخابات
ونؤجل بقتل القضايا للحكومه المنتخب
راينا انه الحديث عن هؤلاء سقطوا هؤلاء
عادوا كذا هذا ليس لديه معنا يجب ان نوسع
القاعده وسعنا قاعده التوافق السياسي
واستسلم الكتله الديمقراطيه طيب الكتله
الديمقراطيه الان تشكل طيف واسعارها
يعني
النقاش ولكن يعني للموضوع يا سيد رايح في
ثواني هل لديك اي رد او تعقيب قبل ان اختم
هذا النقاش
اعتقد ان الجوهر هذه القضيه يتعلق بشيء
محدد هو هناك قوه تريد ان تحتفظ بنظام
القديم البشير القديم وتريد ان تريدها
وتريد ان تواصل في الفساد بتبديل الاوجه
هناك وهو تريد ان تفكك نظام 30 يونيو
وتريد ان تبني نظاما ديمقراطيه جديده
ويؤسس للانتقال السلمي للسلطه شكرا جزيلا
لكم من ريح محمد الصادق انتم معظم مكتبه
تنفيذ الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي
والشكر لكم كذلك الاستاذ المبارك اردول
انتم الامين العام للتوافق الوطني
والقيادي بالحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه كنتما معنا من الخطر